in der Tat wird der Bundeskanzler hier
gleich eine Regierungserklärung abgeben
zum europäischen Gipfel heute und morgen
wo er dann auch hinreisen wird nach den
unruhigen Tagen in der Ampel wird es für
Olaf Scholz in Brüssel sicherlich nicht
viel ruhiger werden denn viele Europäer
sind sauer auf das reiche Deutschland
Deutschland hatte jahrelang auf die
Energie zur aus Russland gesetzt und
dann hat man als das gasnot gab
angefangen mit viel Geld die Gasreserven
überall Aufzug kaufen das hat viele
Europäer ergrenzt und sie haben gesagt
wir wollen jetzt gemeinsam als Europäer
dagegen etwas unternehmen
gemeinschaftsschulden stehen im Raum die
Deutschen haben das bisher immer massiv
abgelehnt die Europäische Kommission hat
vorgestern ihre Maßnahmenpaket vorgelegt
und ist an diesem Punkt vorbeigegangen
sie haben zwar gesagt 40 Milliarden aus
dem Gemeinschaftshaushalt werden wir
aufwenden das sind Mittel die anders
verwendet werden sollten aber nichts von
gemeinschaftlichen Schulden dort zu
hören und des Weiteren im Maßnahmenpaket
ein gasdeckel zumindest für 15 Prozent
gemeinsam ist man einfach stärker so die
Argumentation also es gibt viel zu
besprechen und ich begrüße ganz herzlich
Matthias mir ich von der SPD und Jens
Spahn von der CDU beide stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Herr mir ich habe
es gesagt keine so guten
Ausgangsvoraussetzungen und dann
passiert auch noch das nämlich der
deutsch-französische Ministerrat wird
für nächste Woche abgesagt der
Regierungssprecher hat gestern erklärt
es gibt da Differenzen viele Differenzen
zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich
gerade auch im Energiebereich
Sprichwort Stichwort die Atomkraftwerke
in Frankreich zum Beispiel also viele
Differenzen man hat das abgesagt dass
mitten in dieser Krise da wird auch sich
nur einer freuen können nämlich Herr
Putin wenn diese deutsch-französische
Achse so knirscht ich glaube
Energiepolitik ist immer schon eine
Politik gewesen wo es große Debatten gab
aber wir sehen jetzt gerade dass
Deutschland beispielsweise Frankreich
aushilft weil über die Hälfte der
französischen Atom gar nicht am Netz ist
und der Rat wird meines Erachtens sich
sicherlich auch verständigen auf
wichtige Punkte beispielsweise dass man
eine gemeinsame einkaufstrategie für Gas
auf dem Weg bringt auch an dem Thema
einsparen weiter arbeitet und den
maximalen Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien
nicht zustande kommt also gestern wurde
auch von deutscher Seite erklärt die
deutschen Minister haben zu viel zu tun
das kann es doch nicht sein also ich
mache vieles aber den Pressesprecher für
den französischen Präsidenten oder für
den deutschen Bundeskanzler nicht
insofern müssten sie ihn selbst fragen
wichtig ist dass das auf europäischer
Ebene jetzt gemeinsam geklärt wird und
dafür ist der Rat ja jetzt angesetzt
Herr Spanisch ich habe es gerade
angedeutet die die deutschen stehen
nicht so gut da in Brüssel und jetzt
auch noch dieses Geknirsche zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich lebenswichtig
für die Europäische Union was ist da los
nun ich meine man merkt es ja vielleicht
auch an der Wortwahl gerade bei Herrn
mir Deutschland hält Frankreich aus also
ich finde die Wortwahl schon schwierig
über viele viele Jahre in den letzten
Jahren hat Frankreich Strom vor allem
nach Deutschland exportiert wir brauchen
häufig Strom aus unseren Nachbarländern
diesmal ist es jetzt für einige Monate
andersrum und schon halt hält
Deutschland Frankreich aus wir sind
angewiesen darauf dass es Gas gerade
auch aus Frankreich aus den Niederlanden
aus Belgien aus unseren Nachbarländern
gibt etwa aus den helfenden Rotterdam
und dann werden es gibt kein anderes
Land in Europa in der Europäischen Union
das gerade mehr auf die Solidarität
seiner Nachbarländer angewiesen ist weil
sonst kommt keine Energie kommt kein Gas
zu uns und deswegen würde ich mir schon
wünschen dass da etwas mehr Verständnis
auch für die europäischen Nachbarn und
Partner ist zum Beispiel eben ich finde
das ist so ein no brainer wie man sagt
es ist doch offenkundig in der Zeit wo
ganz Europa einen Strommangel hat und
ein Energiemangel zu sagen alles was
Strom produzieren kann auch in
Deutschland geht ans Netz und bleibt
und da ist eben zum Beispiel das Thema
Kernkraft ja das Thema Kernkraft spaltet
auch die Europäer nicht nur hier die
Ampel aber die hat ja jetzt eine Lösung
gefunden aber kommen wir noch mal auf
Europa und den Auftritt des
Bundeskanzlers dort die
Erwartungshaltung an die Deutschen sind
ja riesig die Deutsch die italienische
und die französische Regierung haben
jetzt noch mal gemeinschaftsschulden ins
Spiel gebracht wäre das ein Weg auch für
die deutsche Regierung es muss auf alle
Fälle jetzt massiv investiert werden und
wir haben jetzt mit den 200 Milliarden
ja etwas auf dem Weg gebracht um
Stabilität zu schaffen für Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und für die Industrie und ich
glaube wir brauchen in Europa auch eine
Debatte was wir zum Beispiel mit der
Wirtschaft machen dass wir dort eben
nicht immer die Beihilfe Fragen stellen
sondern das tatsächlich hier auch mit
massiven Investitionen Wirtschaft und
Industrie gestützt wird zumal wir sehen
was der amerikanische Präsident gerade
parallel dazu mit einem Billionen Dollar
Programm macht aber ich will und das
kann ich ja nicht einfach so hier stehen
lassen weil die Solidarität einzufordern
das ist doch gang und gäbe dass
solidarisch in Europa sind aber Herr
Spahn das gefällt Ihnen natürlich nicht
weil Sie hier den propans Atomkraft in
Deutschland hochfahren das Problem am
augenblicklich ist aber dass die Hälfte
der französischen Atomkraftwerke im
nicht am Netz ist und sie sogar noch im
März beispielsweise ein gas-bargo
gefordert haben dann hätten wir hier
jetzt ganz andere Situationen und
insofern kann ich nur sagen
energiepolitisch Vorwürfe zu machen da
wäre ich Vorsicht wir wollen nicht
zurück gucken sondern nach vorne ganz
klar sollte Deutschland so eine
gemeinschaftsschuldenfonds in Europa
zustimmen also das muss alles
miteinander diskutiert werden ich glaube
Solidarität ist jetzt das Stichwort und
insofern wird der Bundeskanzler
sicherlich in diesem Sinne auch
verhandelt man 200 Milliarden darüber
wird morgen hier im Deutschen Bundestag
gesprochen darauf sind die Europäer
anderen Europäer neidisch kann man
verstehen Deutschland ist reich
Deutschland ist groß und unter Angela
Merkel hat es so gemeinschaftsschulden
ja ganz am Schluss auch gegebene nämlich
bei der corona-pandemie also würden Sie
sagen das ist der richtige Weg um Europa
hier aus der Krise zu führen naja zuerst
wäre es einmal der richtige Weg wenn wir
wüssten wofür diese 200 Milliarden in
Deutschland eigentlich benutzt und
genutzt werden sollen es geht ja nicht
um Investitionen sondern vor allem ja um
Brücken auch finanzielle Brücken zu
bauen für Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
ihre Gas Strompreise nicht mehr bezahlen
können Bäckerhandwerk Mittelstand
Industrie der Winter beginnt die
Heizperiode beginnt und niemand weiß ob
es eine Gas und strompreisbremse gibt
wann sie greift ab welchem Preis niemand
kann kalkulieren das ist das eigentliche
Problem diese große Unsicherheit die da
ist es wird jetzt erstmal Geld morgen
hier im Bundestag beschlossen von dem
keiner weiß wofür es ist und Ampel
Blankoscheck und das ist das was die
Europäer natürlich dann auch unruhig
macht weil sie gar nicht wissen was
macht Deutschland hier eigentlich es war
ja die Vermutung dass wir jetzt
tatsächlich noch mal überall auf der
Welt Gas kaufen und die Preise
hochtreiben übrigens fast alle anderen
europäischen Länder haben schon
Hilfsprogramme für ihre Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Deutschland diskutiert seit sechs
Monaten aber es wird halt nichts
entschieden und dennoch wird gefordert
dass Deutschland sich auf finanzielle in
Europa einbringt noch mal die Frage
ist das ein gangbarer Weg wie bei Corona
nun die Corona Aufbauhilfen die
europäisch miteinander vereinbart wurden
die sind ja noch nicht mal abgeschlossen
also es ist ja nicht so dass wir ein
Geldmangel hätten etwa für Investitionen
in der Europäischen Union das ist ein
bisschen wie in Deutschland
Investitionsmittel die gibt es
mittlerweile genug es ist eher eine
Frage von Planungsrecht ich bin ja froh
dass er Mirsch und seine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen beim Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren jetzt was machen
das unterstützen wir und das gilt in
ganz Europa also es braucht gerade nicht
Schulden es braucht im übrigen auch
nicht viel mehr Geld für Investitionen
es braucht überhaupt mal auch
Veränderungen bei der Bürokratie bei
Auflagen damit Planungen und
Investitionen schneller umgesetzt werden
können was gut wäre wäre wenn die
Kommission wenn der Rat jetzt
beschließen würde keine neuen Auflagen
keine neue Bürokratie mal in den
nächsten vier Jahren wir haben Krise und
die Kommission macht weiter Regulierung
in allen möglichen Bereichen als wir
nichts gewesen schauen wir noch mal auf
heute und morgen in Brüssel die
Kommission vorgestern mit den
Vorschlägen unter anderem wird dort ein
gaspreisdeckelchen vorgeschlagen
15 Prozent sollen gemeinsam eingekauft
werden sind diese Maßnahmen Maßnahmen
die Sie unterstützen werden also auf
alle Fälle ist den Marktmacht die die
Europäische Union hat auszunutzen und
deswegen ist eine gemeinsame
Einkaufsstrategie sicherlich richtig ein
kompletter Deckel würde allerdings den
Markt völlig zu erliegen bringen und es
könnte sein dass Schiffe dann an Deutsch
an Europa insgesamt vorbeifahren und
deswegen ist die Frage wie man die
Handelspolitik organisiert eine
entscheidende und ich gehe davon aus
dass es diesbezüglich dann auch eine
Einigung gibt wenn noch ein Punkt aber
sagen weil das Thema ich dachte oder
hatte gehofft dass die Opposition
mitmacht morgen bei den 200 Milliarden
weil sie sagen sie wissen nicht wofür es
ist ich meine wir haben eine
Expertenkommission die Vorschläge
gemacht hat die jetzt umgesetzt werden
und dazu braucht man die finanziellen
Grundlagen sonst können sie BürgerInnen
und Bürgerinnen und Unternehmen
schlichtweg nicht helfen
sie haben bis heute nicht gesagt was sie
davon umsetzen wollen es ist eineinhalb
Wochen sind vergangen nein eineinhalb
unsere vergangen und niemand weiß was
kommt und sie wollen schon mal Geld wir
wollen den Deckel bezahlen bevor es Bier
bestellt ist das funktioniert nicht
diese Diskussionen können wir hier
morgen führen werden wir auch morgen
früh hier mit Gästen führen und dann im
Bundestag ausgiebig kommen wir noch mal
auf Europa zurück ich glaube das ist der
sechste oder siebte Gipfel wo man
versucht bei den Energiepreisen etwas
gemeinschaftlich zu unternehmen
man kommt nicht so recht voran weil zum
Beispiel in der Frage Atomkraft 27
Länder haben völlig unterschiedlichen
Energiemix da ist man sehr gespalten nun
hat Frau von der Leyen gesagt es muss
solidarischer Sache gehen es gibt diesen
sos-mechanismus dass man sich
gegenseitig hilft da sind bisher erst
sechs Abkommen bilateral geschlossen
worden 40 müssten es mindestens sein
Deutschland hat so ein Abkommen mit
Österreich und der Schweiz glaube ich
nein mit den Niederlanden und warum
scheitert das zum Beispiel dass man
untereinander diese Dinger das hätte man
längst abschließen müssen das ist ein
Mechanismus in hat man 2018 eingeführt
genau deutschland braucht 9 dieser
Verträge mit allen Nachbarländern nach
EU-Recht und es geht darum wer hilft wem
wie in einer zum Beispiel gasmangelage
und die kommen die Bundesregierung
berichtet uns seit Monaten dass Sie in
guten Gesprächen wäre mein Eindruck ist
es gibt halt Vorbehalte bei unseren
Nachbarn unter anderem wegen unserer
Energiepolitik sie haben den Eindruck
Deutschland ist nicht bereit alles was
es könnte etwa eben beim Thema Kohle und
Kernkraft einzubringen in dieser
Krisenlage und das führt zu einer großen
Zurückhaltung bei diesen Verträgen das
gilt übrigens auch bei der
Einkaufsgemeinschaft ja recht es macht
Sinn dass die Europäische Union
gemeinsam einkauft nur hat das ja bisher
die Bundesregierung verhindert also sehr
gut dass sie jetzt umschwenkt das kann
ich nur begrüßen weil natürlich wenn die
Europäische Union gemeinsam einkauft wir
uns nicht gegenseitig die Preise
hochtreiben insofern da verändert die
Bundesregierung jetzt nach sechs Monaten
ihre Haltung auch das führt vielleicht
dazu dass auch Partnerländer in Europa
wieder bereit sind mehr mit uns zu
machen Einkaufspreise ist das Stichwort
beim Gaspreis da soll auch etwas gemacht
werden der ttf-fonds
den Niederlanden soll ergänzt werden das
ist ja alles sehr kompliziert wir sehen
das beim Strom berühmte married order es
wird nach dem teuersten bezahlt das hat
man mal übrigens eingeführt damit die
Erneuerbaren dabei gut wegkommt in die
sind immer billiger in der Herstellung
ist es eigentlich gut wenn die Politik
in solchen Mechanismus Mechanismen so
rumfummelt wir haben absolute
Krisenzeiten und wir sehen dass es zu
völlig abstrusen Preisbildung im Moment
kommt aufgrund dieser Mechanismen und
deswegen muss man in diesen Krisenzeiten
auch solche Mechanismen aufs Eis legen
bzw andere finden wie jetzt
beispielsweise beim Flüssiggas gerade
heute versucht wird ja ich war noch mal
die Frage auch an sie was kann man da
tun beim Preis also gemeinschaftlich
einkaufen aber auch die
verrechnungsmethoden sind ja so dass man
die sowieso als Laie nicht versteht aber
dass sie offensichtlich auch nicht
sinnvoll sind
also grundsätzlich sind hohe Preise
erstmal im Markt ein Zeichen dafür dass
was knapp ist es gibt nicht genug
Angebot sie sind komme ich immer wieder
dahin zurück alles was ans Netz kann
muss ans Netz das allein schon
stabilisiert die Preise das zweite ist
zu schauen beim Gaseinkauf zum Beispiel
klar geht es nicht um festen Preis nicht
ein Preis Deckel aber einen atmen im
Preis Deckel für die Europäische Union
beim Einkauf in der Welt zu haben beim
gemeinsam das macht schon Sinn also
immer so dass wir über allen anderen
liegen aber halt nicht so dass es
Richtung Mond geht da gibt's kluge
Mechanismen wenn man sich darauf
verständigte wäre das schon ein
wichtiger Schritt nach vorne Problem ist
nur die Kommission sagt selber dass alle
ihre Vorschläge die jetzt besprochen
werden in den nächsten Tagen nicht mehr
für diesen Winter helfen werden es geht
die alle Vorschläge sind für
übernächsten Winter weil der noch
schwieriger wahrscheinlich werden wird
wir müssen aber jetzt erstmal gut durch
diesen Winter und da wird diese
Koalition und diese Regierung endlich
mal handeln müssen mein Stichwort der
Winter wird kompliziert werden vor allen
Dingen für die Ukraine nicht nur weil
sie angegriffen wird und tausendfach
Menschen dort sterben sondern die
Infrastruktur wird ja von den Russen
jetzt auch massiv zerstört was hilft ein
Sacharow-Preis wenn die Leute dort
frieren wie werden wir uns verhalten
können wir Energie und müssen wir nicht
Energie abgeben Richtung der Ukraine
auch da ist Solidarität jetzt gefragt
und da laufen ja auch Gespräche und das
Zentrum ist jetzt dass wir tatsächlich
unabhängig werden und ich kann nur sagen
Herr Spahn das was die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland gerade die Bundesregierung
in den letzten Monaten gemacht hat ist
das Thema Versorgungssicherheit
sicherzustellen unter Peter Altmaier
waren die Gasspeicher leer sie sind
jetzt soweit wie möglich gefüllt und
insofern haben wir ganz ganz viel auch
mit Kohlekraft Reaktivierung jetzt getan
um in diesem Land versorgen Sicherheit
darzustellen und das wird auch dann für
andere Länder auch gegebenenfalls für
die die in Not kommen mit hilfreich sein
ich kann gucken wir noch mal auf Brüssel
haben Sie eigentlich Hoffnung dass er
von diesem Gipfel greifbare Ergebnisse
kommen werden denn die Ungarn zum
Beispiel die fährt das alles nicht die
kriegen weiter ihre Energie aus Russland
es gibt viele Länder die setzen auf
Atomkraft andere tun das nicht es ist ja
ein heilloses Durcheinander und dort das
zu sortieren und wirklich Ergebnisse zu
zeitigen also das ist schwierig wie ist
ihre Hoffnung ist das wieder einer von
den vielen Gipfeln die so vergehen
werden also zuerst mal unter Sigmar
Gabriel wurden die Gasspeicher an die
Russen verkauft wir können jetzt hier
dieses Pingpong machen ich glaube wir
alle hatten dann haben nur die
Bundesliga alle hatten da und sie haben
glaube ich mitregiert wenn mich richtig
erinnere eine Fehleinschätzung in den
letzten Jahren naja was diesen rattern
geht man kann es sich nur wünschen
genauso wie wir endlich Geschlossenheit
innerhalb der Regierung in Deutschland
bräuchten wir wissen ja bis heute
zwischen Finanz- und Wirtschaftsminister
nicht wer will was bräuchten wir eben
auch möglichst viel Geschlossenheit
Gemeinsamkeit in der Europäischen Union
das ist eine wahnsinnig tiefe Krise
viele Menschen sind unsicher haben Sorge
gerade vor dem nächsten Winter
einheitliches gemeinsames Handeln in
Deutschland und in der EU kann
dazuversicht geben wer mir schon bei
Ihnen die Erwartungshaltung ja wir
brauchen auf alle Fälle jetzt eine
starke europäische Union und deswegen
sind die nächsten beiden Tage auch ganz
wichtig
ja vielen Dank mir ist ersparen dass sie
da waren meine Damen und Herren sie
haben es gemerkt innenpolitisch wird
doch viel überlagert über die Frage
Atomkraft oder nicht das ist eine Europa
natürlich auch so aber nicht so krass
wie hier in Deutschland sondern da geht
es um andere Fragen gemeinsamer Einkauf
man guckt natürlich immer wieder nach
Deutschland die haben 200 Milliarden
doppelwumms können wir davon nicht was
abkriegen das sind Mechanismen die sind
ja bekannt und ich habe es schon paar
mal erwähnt diese Sitzung da in Brüssel
heute und morgen da muss man abwarten ob
hinterher wirklich ziel war es dabei
rauskommt jedenfalls wird der
Bundeskanzler hier gleich seine
Regierungserklärung abhalten und er wird
sie sicherlich viel zu erklären haben
dass eben die deutsch-französische
Ministerrunde kommenden Mittwoch
abgesagt wurde gestern das ist schon
überraschend und das ist auch nicht gut
in Zeiten wo Europa eigentlich
zusammenhalten müsste wenn diese Achse
schwächelt und damit gebe ich rein in
den Plenarsaal